there's gotta be peak oil but there
isn't but that could be we're going to
go through the top five examples
examples that are not up for debate
where the left has gotten it verifiably
Falls peoples of all you see they're
always wrong and of course we try to
source everything will provide overlays
but in this case we're going to go
through some very very specific examples
but I want to lead with this with the
whole Russia witch-hunt right now and
the FBI and well president Trump wanting
to investigate the FBI more Americans
right now when you look at the polls
have less faith in our institutions than
ever but could that be a good is that
really that bad of a thing I understand
that we need some faith in our
institutions we need some we need to
have some respect for the office but
it's a bad thing for Americans say you
know what turns out that the FBI can be
politicized turns out I don't
necessarily know that I trust some of
these organizations I go back to science
people it's nice I go back and forth of
it I would love your opinions also some
other examples if you think of the right
or the left getting it wrong
historically so recently this is where
the left got it wrong they said that
Trump was not spied on by the Obama
administration they claimed the FBI was
not spying on Trump remember this
everyone yeah you can go look for more
source we haven't never would happen so
much spies but there were spy we just
call them informants here in their own
words what about this notion that there
was a CI a confidential informant
embedded in the campaign is that true
well as we've seen unfortunately the the
identity of this informant is now out
and if you know this is a fairly benign
tool available to the FBI given all the
other capabilities available to them we
could have screwed you worse is that
what I'm talking about
never gets called it we just talked
about this last week with Venezuela was
the only Hong people who were wrong it
wasn't the informants are not spies
naturally but if we move on on that yeah
but it's okay
you're saying drop Israel yeah he's
right but stop stop the word after
making sentences that are coming out of
your mouth and this has happened for a
long time let me run you through some
examples so let's go
top five number five is peak oil my
favorite number this this I don't know
how many bumper stickers yeah and on how
many signs of the term peak oil so much
of them now they don't use that term
people say what do you mean happy couple
since the 1950s right the left has
repeatedly claimed that we'll reach a
point of maximum extraction of oil
resources but this specifically applies
to petroleum but generally they kind of
apply it to overall resources that when
it's reached we're gonna reach this
terminal decline because a hit oil as
recently as 2010 by the way Paul Krugman
claimed that Peak Oil has arrived
oops right you've never seen these kinds
of costs of the pump as you do in 2018
so what's the truth
this is proven verifiably fault us hit a
record high in oil production alone in
November last year then an even higher
record in February we have we have
arguably more access today today to
natural resource to to gasoline and
natural gas than ever in recorded
history and we're finding new ways but
imagine if we'd have enacted the policy
that the left claimed we needed but
we're not even getting to climate change
just the peak oil yeah not true ok
number four I've talked about this but I
think it's pretty important aids all
right
listen the left claimed that aids was
gonna turn these Clinton already was an
epidemic yep everybody Oprah said about
aids I think she said this in the in the
in 1990
maybe [ __ ] in 1989 she said aids as both
sexes running scared research studies
now predict that one in five listen to
me hard to believe
yes Oprah one in five heterosexuals will
be dead or could be dead from AIDS at
the end of the next three years
one in five believe me no aids became
the single most research funded diseases
research funded Z's ever in modern
American history despite being a
statistical non risk money that could've
been better spent on Oh cancer or the
kid with diabetes that he didn't ask to
be born with
you don't want to catch anything that
it's a it's not a one in five stat if
you are not having gay anal sex and a
truckstop with complete strangers are
using hypodermic needles that you're
sharing with other people guess what
you're suggesting agent North America is
zero percent more money than any disease
in modern America thanks Oprah number
three this is a big one the star wars
missile defense system this is something
that everyone
and you've probably heard this term to
the point where you even think that it
was Ronald Reagan's term it's not spent
computers gonna educate him NASA that us
on that a little bit later
everyone marked President Reagan and
said it would never work let's roll some
clips many American politicians and
scientists campaigned against what they
saw as Reagan's expensive folly
the heavens are for wonder not for war
stop star wars stop weapons in space
Reagan's predicts SDI was hugely
expensive and would never work they were
appalled by the deep cuts in welfare
programs that would be needed to pay for
it we'll talk about that with with Mark
Levin later that's it you know you look
at Winston Churchill he was immediately
ousted yeah after his first general
election because I thank you for helping
protect us now we want free crap yeah
that's what happened couldn't believe
they'd be cutting welfare to protect
themselves from the Communists Russians
and nuclear missiles not understanding
the role of government or the truth
right they mock they mock the defense
system which Ronald Reagan had they
coined it star wars missile defense
system the ensuing Londres helped
bankrupt the Soviet Union in the system
by the way it's used today it works
perfectly in Israel it's used in cities
across the globe today we know that it
works but they use this term star wars
missile defense to make it sound like
there was a stupid actor but at the same
time they were advocating a nuclear
disarmament mm-hmm you know that's not
only about the missile defense system
they didn't think we should have nukes
at all do you do you give us that one
spend computer you were saying but the
star wars missile defense yes so trying
to find who actually coined that term
yes so so I reckon they were used to
terms that was defense system he counted
Strategic Defense Initiative right and
then an author baby named arthur c
clarke wrote science fiction books
apparently used the term in front of
congress and then all the media latch
onto that because they thought was
genius they just called star wars never
let a good story get in the way of the
actual facts they could probably
actually help people but it's more fun
to make fun of somebody and say star
wars than rights protect against movie
well the thing is it's this is actually
one of those deals where if you try to
google it all the articles say Ronald
Reagan's Star Wars missile defense
system yeah they all actually attributed
it to him because they wanted people to
think that he was a dumb actor a dumb
actor who stared down on the Soviet
Union by the way and one you were wrong
about that you're wrong about the
missile defense initiative and you were
wrong about nuclear disarmament right
right okay number two this one's really
important about the model Cities program
parentheses all subsequent government
welfare programs designed thereafter so
this is one that is again very yeah we
don't we don't want to sit here and
debate social
with you on a philosophical level what
do you think it's a moral imperative to
share okay we were just going to look at
some examples here concrete data can we
admit that the war on poverty in the
United States hasn't worked up everyone
can we can we admit that it failed it
hasn't worked statistically the model
Cities program right if we look back at
Lyndon Johnson Detroit was one of the
model sees they took a city that was the
wealthiest city in the country and said
now we're gonna put in some welfare
incentives we're gonna we're gonna
piggyback off of the success of Detroit
and claim credit for it and there goes
Detroit Wow oh well that blame the
Republicans the welfare state destroyed
families it incentivized single
motherhood since launching the war on
poverty out of wedlock births of
skyrocketed poverty has been nearly
completely unaffected I mean it's one of
the war on poverty the model Cities
program this is one that they said this
was going to solve the problem and of
course if you look at it not only the
model cities not solve the problem but
then you look at other programs oh well
this is going to solve the problem and
then you end up putting band-aids on top
of the tourniquet that you initially put
on there one there you couldn't you
couldn't fix the wound I get the spirit
of it yeah you don't want war oh I get
the spirit of it you don't want poverty
wouldn't either do we the difference is
historically you were wrong historically
you were do you realize that Tom Hanks
did you ever see them in on MSNBC where
he talked about world war two he said we
went into World War two I don't know the
exact quote based on fear mongering and
racism yeah this is the guy who's the
Saving Private Ryan World War two isn't
that one that you would just kind of we
all fight we talk about common ground
World War two is awarded an argue over I
don't know how we get here all right
which brings us to number one cuz we
talked about this last week Venezuela
this is really a forgery because it
obviously points to socialism at large
but the left consistently and now
they're trying to distance themselves
this is your child
this is your child you know there's a
striking resemblance Bernie bad so the
left praised Venezuela and of course
other South American socialist countries
ad nauseam rule clips so here you have
an extremely rich American Thinker Dome
some policies happened to be it's felt
by the population they've got the first
country and everybody was totally
convinced the Castro was the worst guy
in the world
all the Cuban people were gonna rise up
in rebellion against Fidel Castro
they'd forgot that he educated the kids
gave them health care totally
transformed a society you know 20
sometimes American journalists talk
about how bad the country is because
people are lining up the food that's a
good thing this is one of those things
where again they they just and they move
on their neck saying well they didn't do
socialism properly he was praising
Castro by the way that's not that you
can also find Michael Moore claiming
that Cuba's health care system was
better than the United States as
recently as sicko and I remember because
of a poll the Canadian Press praised it
so now only now are they trying to
distance themselves kept here's
something else that's really telling to
me when you look at that he says he
forgets the Castro gave them health care
Oh what does that mean about burning
Kate listen Bernie bros you'll love me
think oh socialism when working there I
says what does that tell you about
Bernie it tells you that Bernie believes
Castro has the authority to grant you
health care hatton which means he has
the authority to take away your rights
if you take away the right from private
companies look at what happened in
Venezuela you saw John Oliver praising
the fact that Chavez took control over
the banks and they decided to fire
executives they cheered for that should
tell you if Bernie Sanders is ever
elected to office he believes that he
can grant you rights like free health
care like free internet like free insert
whatever it is you want here and he also
believes that he will have the authority
to take those away that is bone-chilling
ly scary spoiler alert
everyone's starving in Venezuela okay it
looks like The Karate Kid bullies in
their skeleton costumes it is an
absolute horror show in Venezuela
everybody now acknowledges that it sucks
and I think that we can all agree that
Cuba didn't do so well under Castro for
a while did Bernie Sanders come out and
apologize for
let alone ven as well did Sean Penn
can't say oh wow you know what I was
wrong maybe he's not the most beautiful
human being alive they never get called
on it Joe Biden makes up stories about
meeting people that he's never met in
places that don't even exist right now
we're telling us today we're not spying
on Trump hey what about this spy well
yeah we do have informants on trouble
you just said you didn't I don't know
what you're talking about
keep moving on what were you gonna say
something that you said well yeah just
wonder if the left just loves lies I
mean is they love these lies and they
believe live by them just like they like
the lies that
artificially inflating prices of
gasoline does it cop say for peak the
lack of peak oil yeah they just love the
longer or not but we have a major supply
god oil but there isn't but there isn't
there's no it's not burning unless you
get your policies implemented you
authoritarian poll by the way this is
not even to mention some of the more
current topics we want to hear from you
what you think are prime examples this
doesn't even include Obamacare claiming
that it would lower premiums deductibles
while you could keep your doctor's if
you like your doctors dodd-frank and of
course the fact that Donald Trump would
never ever ever be president look at the
tables on Al Gore and use the Internet
to our advantage if you like this video
subscribe by hitting the subscribe
button or the notification bell next to
it because subscribing isn't enough
watch one of these other videos and you
know listen you can you can stick around
you don't have to but here's the thing
the fact that you're still listening to
me saying stick around as I say stick
around and you're sticking around a bow
we just added another add you just made
me for more sense